parlons justement d'économie avec Pierre
Feth guebwen qui est le ministre de
l'économie de l'innovation de l'énergie
de la région de Montréal de Montréal du
développement économique régional j'ai
tout dit c'est pas mal ça bonsoir
Monsieur
Merci beaucoup est-ce que vous est-ce
que vous êtes David la récession d'abord
va frapper le Québec et est-ce que ça
vient contrer un peu les ambitions que
vous avez pour le développement
d'économie
récession relations économistes définies
sociaux ou non mais je pense que depuis
quelques mois nous anticiper au
ralentissement évidemment la demande de
surchauffée on a vu la hausse de taux
d'intérêt pour redresser l'inflation on
avait parlé ils vont un impact sur les
individus monsieur Gérard va adresser ça
dans les prochains mois pour les mesures
qu'on tactique on va faire pour les
entreprises qui ne préoccupent plus
évidemment je pense qu'on va voir une
situation de problèmes de liquidité
parce que les entreprises font face à un
offre qui est un peu défaillante le
cycle de la chaîne d'approvisionnement
est brisé vous aimez les égards donc on
doit mettre beaucoup d'inventaires pour
pouvoir produire donc il va des enjeux
dans le premier qui vont être requis
liquidités pour payer les menteurs il va
falloir nous via Investissement Québec
via les programmes que nous avons mis en
place le féli et être à l'écoute des
entreprises pour pouvoir combler un
déficit de liquidité est-ce que vous
préférez déjà ça un programme d'aide
pour les entreprises nous on est
vraiment on reçoit un peu ce qui se
passe on observe et moi je pense qu'il
va avoir un avancement économique
heureusement à cause du plein emploi
pratiquement l'impact va être moindre
alors c'est un impact plutôt pas de
perte de performance mais plutôt un
impact de l'investissement qu'on va
devoir faire des entreprises pour
pouvoir pallier votre gouvernement
prépare quelque chose présentement pour
les entreprises du Québec on regarde
effectivement comment on va réagir et on
est prêt déjà parce que toutes les
programmes qui ont été mis en place
c'est pour ça que ce soit les mêmes
programmes mais on a des gens sur le
terrain qui sont déjà prêt est-ce que ça
remet en question votre stratégie parce
que vous vous êtes toujours en train de
faire la stratégie économique pour le
Québec compte tenu que la récession nous
arrive est-ce que vous remettez en
question client ce que vous êtes en
train de préparer non la destination va
être la même le parcours pour s'y rendre
plus difficile on parle d'une période de
12 à 18 mois quand je parle de mon
collègue monsieur Gérard on parle de
2023 qui va être difficile donc
maintenant on est on fait des programmes
pour les prochaines années donc la
stratégie ne change pas faut que je sais
juste à conséquence durant la période
qui va nous faire face l'année prochaine
et là vous vous devenez aussi ministre
de l'Énergie c'était Jonathan Julien qui
est en charge de l'énergie vous étiez en
charge de l'économie dont économie
énergie qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce que ça
vous permet que l'ancienne mouture ne
vous permettait pas mais en fait quant
au mois de au printemps j'ai discuté
avec monsieur Legault le mandat qu'on
voulait avoir pour le deuxième terme on
a regardé les objectifs de monsieur
Legault il était très clair on veut
combler l'écart de richesse avec
l'Ontario qui est de la richesse
collective pour investir là ça n'a pas
changé c'est ce qui m'anapolitique quand
je regarde les prochains disent à 15 ans
la vision économique du développement
économique que je suis responsable
il y a deux chantiers importants
l'innovation qui est au rendez-vous dans
les entreprises on a parlé beaucoup avec
vous d'ailleurs toute la question
positivité robotisation on a parlé de
lancer à aller au printemps dernier la
Stratégie québécoise la recherche
investissement de l'innovation
là-dedans l'autre pilier c'est comment
utiliser l'énergie renouvelable de façon
de façon parcimonieuse et efficace
pourquoi parce que d'une part on doit
des carboner le Québec et d'autre part
on peut mettre en harmonie l'économie et
l'environnement et je pense que
l'énergie va devenir un levier
maintenant vous faire attention
effectivement faut être prudent on va
pas donner l'électricité à n'importe qui
mais je pense que des projets qui sont
souhaitables qu'on fait ça que notre
atout d'énergie pas cher puis
d'électricité pas cher finalement nous
amène à être le Dollarama d'énergie
comme dit Madame Brochu chez hydro il
faut effectivement être parcimonieux
nous n'aurons pas assez d'électricité
pour tous les projets sur mon bureau à
présentement pendant le double triple de
ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui donc
conséquemment nous devons comme
gouvernement ont décidé où on a lu
l'énergie seront fait depuis plusieurs
années d'ailleurs là dans un contexte de
pénurie possible d'électricité il faut
être très perçu évaluer les retombées
économiques et exagérer de dire pénurie
d'électricité au Québec un peu du riz
peut-être ce mot mauvais mot mais je
pense qu'on n'aura pas tous les tester
qu'on aurait besoin pour tout faire les
projets qui pourraient être rentable
pour le Québec conséquemment pour faire
une grille d'évaluation donc nous sommes
économie on reçoit les projets on va
regarder avec les Québec quel est
l'offre possible quelle est la
différence quels sont les mesures de
remédiation on peut être plus efficace
de la consommation on peut mieux
turbiner nos barrages existants plus
d'éolien l'énergie haute et de
l'électrique de l'éolien mais aussi de
la biomasse il y a beaucoup de
d'alternatives donc réévaluer
ça c'est les résultats
qu'on va faire
depuis plusieurs mois on est déjà des
rencontres monsieur Julien moi Madame
Brochu et monsieur Legault pour regarder
quels sont les projets il faut des
carboner le Québec 44% de transport 29%
des GS c'est l'industrie sont 13 %. donc
c'est quoi le portrait-robot des projets
que vous voulez au Québec
il y a des filières intéressantes que
les batteries par exemple moi je pense
que un des éléments le plus important au
Québec c'est que nous matière première
nous ressources soient converties de
plus en aval possible créer de la
richesse la batterie de mon exemple on
prend du lithium on prend du graphite on
prend du nickel ils sont les capables de
pas exporter ce produit même de garder
ici créer de la valeur c'est intéressant
parlons d'aluminium 30 secondes on
risque on risque on peut devenir le
premier État mondial afin d'aluminium
vert ça veut dire quoi ça
on va acheter de l'aluminium vert pour
que nos produits soient une prime alors
à ce moment-là faut peut-être moduler
moins exporter peut-être moi j'aimerais
qu'on utilise toutes nos ressources ici
au Québec parce que là exporter en ce
moment ça fait en sorte que c'est l'état
de New York qui se retrouve avec des
gros contrats d'IBM et de Micron
notamment bon soit un enjeu je pense que
Madame Bochu a fait un très bon du
travail pour le contrôle de New York par
exemple un bon prix puis aussi de la
gestion du réseau faire attention c'est
c'est pas de l'ail noir tout ça mais
clairement dans le futur je pense être
très percimonieux très rigoureux autant
de pas jeûne absolument passer en
économie personne environnement parce
qu'aujourd'hui social ou alors c'est sûr
il y a une table de concertation qui a
été créée monsieur De Gaulle qui est la
table qui va permettre à tous les
intervenants incluant le ministre de
l'Environnement qui est très important a
décidé si c'est la bonne utilisation de
nos ressources pour l'instant madame
Brochu dit
je vais poursuivre avec vous elle a dit
ça à ses employés elle reste PDG des
rois au Québec mais si dans le comité
qui est formé par Monsieur le goût avec
vous s'il n'est pas d'accord avec la
stratégie du gouvernement sur le plan
d'énergie on fait quoi
je pense que les objectifs de madame lui
dire ben écoutez ça marche pas on va
changer de PDG on n'est pas là du tout
moi je pense que les objectifs de Madame
Brochu qui gère et au Québec
issu du gouvernement sont totalement
alignés une question c'est l'arbitrage
où on donne notre énergie et moi je suis
ouvert à tout considérer c'est pas parce
que le ministre d'économie
on le voit l'inviter à la table pour
qu'elle puisse comprendre l'enjeu du
chose il est au Québec fait des profits
le gouvernement a fait lui aussi alors
faut regarder l'ensemble de l'oeuvre
quand on dit que les gens viennent voler
l'électricité pour faire attention ils
étaient des retombées économiques à
l'extérieur du Québec il faut considérer
mais ça c'est une question de
transparence d'information je pense
madame brochure va être très à l'aise de
pouvoir participer ce débat dernier
point Journal de Montréal encore une
fois ce matin parle d'une entreprise
dans laquelle le ministère de l'Économie
a investi vous étiez administrateur de
lumineux vous avez des liens
amicaux je veux dire est-ce que ça vous
agace qu'on ramène
continuellement des apparences de
conflits d'intérêt vous tous je pense
que c'est une situation pas du tout
affectée par ce que
une rigueur au niveau du jardin c'est
pas le musée du matin je pense faut
comprendre comment fonctionne un engin
gouvernemental tout le projet du nulle
part je suis très fier on va faire
d'autre d'ailleurs comme celle-là toute
cette transactions il y a une rigueur au
niveau d'investissement Québec c'est
arrivé au bureau à la fin il y a pas de
conflit d'intérêt puis au Canada
attention on veut mais il y a des
rigueurs
qu'il y a des conflits faut regarder ce
qui se passe dans le cas présent le
processus d'approbation des
investissements autant chez
Investissement Québec ou mi est très
rigoureux et il n'y a pas eu de
manifestation
de vous retrouver et de vous recevoir
merci beaucoup d'avoir été merci
beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]